friends we have been told by the mystics
we have been told by the ones we respect
the
most that the
problem with our existential
distress is that
it's well it lacks
perspective it is like a monoculture
you're sort of stuck in the egoic shell
and the problem with that singular
perspective is that it robs you from the
communion and connection and trans
scaler Ecstasy of experiencing aesh the
hardly bearable Ecstasy of Direct Energy
exploding on our nerve endings as
Timothy ly said what do I mean by this
well it seems that we are suspended in
Paradox we are at once mortal and divine
we are at once fetching water and
chopping wood try to survive as a
fragile being stuck in time but we we
are at the same time a marvelous conduit
in a Timeless hole from which molecules
and meanings flow from neurons to nebula
and back again we are part of a
continuity we are part of a trans scaler
isness a quality of being that is
mathematics that exist instead of
nothing that we come from a lineage of
beingness that exceeds us
the fact that there is something instead
of nothing proves at
once God it proves at once that there
are mathematical forces at play there
are properties of being there are
particles and wave functions and
elements and chemistry and
patterning there is self-organizing
assemblages of being meaness that exists
trans scalar below us above us Beyond us
beneath us before us and after us and
are not separate from us and the
realization at once that we are away for
the cosmos to know itself but we are not
separate from that Cosmos and we are
instead a flourishing that becomes aware
that it is a conduit a marvelous conduit
in a Timeless hole from which molecules
and meanings flow from neurons to nebula
and back again we are the nebul we are
the neurons we are the particles we are
the atoms we are the self transforming
machine elves we are the hophen is thing
that is born out of nothing we are the
patterns of information that governs the
properties of biology and we are the
chemistry that leads to that biology and
we are the atoms that lead to the
physics that lead to the celestial
bodies that lead to the goldilock zone
that lead to the self-organizing
assemblages of self-aware entities that
are talking about what we are that is a
mystical experience the final seeing of
the all of it quality of our being the
mysterium tremendum is the realization
that is like a shattering and also an
ejaculatory moment of being at once
autop poesis the thing that creates
itself out of nothing all of it Cosmos
you a mere droplet in a sea of being
that which exists instead of nothing and
that should be enough to put us that
existential ease that we are part of
something incandescent that shines with
the light of creation nothing dies in
this
perspective nothing begins and nothing
ends only
transforms and there is Beauty in this
realization there is Beauty and Grace in
this realization the kind of Grace that
we need more of In This World As We Ride
The Human Experience into the
cosmos
let us remember who we
are let us remember who we
are and let us
Relish in this
ravishing let us Relish in this
ravishing